I literally was putting everything that
I had on the line for something people
just laughed at me and said wait audio
over the Internet
you know you can turn on the radio it's
your company and you can't sell you're
not gonna be in business long
particularly when you're starting up and
it's just you when I talk to
entrepreneurs you have to make a
decision what's important to you need
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
nation
he's Mark Cuban and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success volume six
enjoy
okay let's kick out for rule number one
take risk a Fiat x19 that had a hole in
the floorboard I mean you could tell I
was living the high life right I mean
and I was putting in oil every sixty
miles and you know working as a
bartender at night what did I have to
lose you know and so it wasn't like haha
man you know this is I can lose all this
and yeah and so it was just like you
just go for it now later on after I'd
had some success and we got back and we
started audio net which turned into
broadcast comm that the math was
different the equations you know the
calculus was different it was like okay
I'm investing a lot of my save money
into this whole idea of net casting
right or internet broadcasting in early
1995 when people didn't even know what
the internet was that was all risk
because I literally was putting
everything that I had on the line for
something people just laughed at me and
said wait audio over the Internet you
know you can turn on the radio you know
you know you can turn on the TV yeah but
you don't get it no that's just dumb all
right you know and and so being able to
overcome all that resistance because
remember back then hey you had to have a
PC B you had to know what a modem was
and install it see you had to know what
the internet was and then you had to
download a tcp/ip client that worked
over a modem and then connected to a
browser that you probably didn't even
know what it was or how to download it
and we had to take it on faith that all
this was going to grow rule number two
know how to sell sales cures all lots of
companies come in and say I have a great
idea or I have a company and we've got
some sales but we only need to do this
and we only need to do that and you talk
to them and you talk to the entrepreneur
and I'm like why aren't you selling this
is your whole company there's never been
a company in the history of companies to
live to survive without sales and so I
think you know now as more and more
people watch Shark Tank they're seeing
it
but if you can't sell if it's your
company and you can't sell you're not
going to be in business long
particularly when you're starting up and
it's just you and sales is not something
you can give to somebody else and say
okay I'm just gonna hire salespeople
Michael humectant that guy I told you
about that fired me for hand him the
check he was the guy who wouldn't see he
was the CEO and owner he would never
sell he thought he could just bring us
in and sell it and the company failed
afterwards you got a sell rule number
three decides what's important to you
what I advise people when I when I sat
down to make a decision I my goal always
was I wanted to retire by the time I was
35 right period end of story and I sold
my first company micro solutions and I
was going to be willing to live like a
student I was 20 I just turned 30 I
guess and I bought a lifetime pass in
American Airlines and just party like a
rock star
I was getting up with as many people as
I possibly could and go into as many
countries as much as I could in love in
life and that was my goal right and then
came back and started buying and selling
stocks made another twenty five million
dollars whatever is crushing it then we
started audio net and I financed it out
of my pocket for till we got big enough
where we wanted strategics and again on
one hand we're doing a million people a
day coming in doing multimedia in
1998-1999
we are doing when we sold Yahoo our last
quarter I think we did 23 million in
revenue and 1999 dollars right so on the
internet on the Internet yeah all just
on the Internet are people paying you to
do webcast yeah yeah I mean it's
shocking the things that we created back
then that out that if I were to patent
it it would have been a different world
pre-roll ads we started that pop-up ads
we call them guarantee clicks where we
started that multicast distribution all
kinds of stuff you know different ways
of connecting servers writing software
around all kinds of um but in my mind it
wasn't about I wanted to create this
huge company I'm never telling our
employees we're gonna change where I
want to be the next Ted Turner I want to
just change cable change television I
wanted to change media I want all media
to be driven online that it's going to
be crazy to think that there aren't
going to be more choices online than
there are TV people are going to upload
use of Gen
rated content and that's gonna change
the world and you know not the word the
country I wasn't thinking that big um
but more importantly more important to
me then was my personal freedom right
the one thing my dad has always driven
to me the one thing you can't own is
time you know and the one thing you
can't give back as time and while the
part of me wanted a mazing world-class
company a bigger part of me just wanted
to see the world you know and just
experience the world and just love life
and just enjoy life and that was more
important to me and that's what the
money enable and that's why when you
know that's why I hedged my stock I
didn't need more I just wanted more time
you know because that that was
everything to me and so when I talked to
entrepreneurs you have to make a
decision what's important to you time to
go out and do whatever be whoever you
are help you ever you want to help raise
your family whatever it is or do you
want to create a world-class company
what is your goal and you have to
understand your goals and there should
always be a price you know if there's a
if it is about selling at some point
what's the price ruinin before keep up
with modern technology I focus on things
that are AI driven artificial
intelligence driven whether it's machine
learning deep nerdy learning neural
networks medical applications but within
ai ai is a buzzword that everybody is
using right now you know every in and to
that point you know we as all guys we go
back and it's like 1995 we talk about
the internet and I would say to people
back in 1995 look if you don't
understand the Internet you're not gonna
be able to do business and now that's
just blocking the tackling that seems
obvious back then it wasn't right I
could even take you further back to my
first company you know what we did was a
company called micro solutions and we
did local area networks on wide area
networks and I used to walk into
companies and say you're gonna have to
hook these pcs together at some point
that'll make you more productive more
effective you know give you a
competitive advantage and people are
like now I just carry this floppy from
this PC to that PC yeah okay but today
we're at the same type of inflection
point with artificial intelligence
you don't have to be an expert and be
able to put together your own neural
network you know you don't have to know
what weights and biases are but but you
have to have more than just a cursory
understanding just like you have to know
the difference between you know
different types of websites and you have
to understand ecommerce if you're in the
e-commerce you have to have a cursory
understanding of how apps work you're
gonna have to have at least if not more
cursory understanding of artificial
intelligence because it will change
everything we do and if the internet was
10x in terms of change to business
artificial intelligence will be 100 X or
more so there's going to be a disruption
and change in the types of jobs that's
going to impact your customers that's
going to impact your businesses that's
going to impact the future of business
and so I can't I don't want to be you
know I want to be as clear and as
forceful as I possibly can because as
fellow entrepreneurs we always have to
look for an edge we always have to
understand how our industry is changing
we always have to understand not only
how we differentiate ourselves and our
companies but you always I always want
to know who can kick my ass right and
all my businesses who can kick my ass
and can I kick my own ass first because
if you can disrupt yourself first you're
the person who could otherwise do it is
not going to do it and you can compete
and be successful so pay attention to AI
it's important if you go to my house
right next to my bed there's a book
machine learning for dummies if you go
into my bathroom there's deep neural
networks for dummies right if you go
home there's a something for dummies in
every room of my house you know they
could go two ways I know but I'm just
telling you put the time I mean I've
taken you know I can't even tell you how
many hours now I spend every week if not
daily working like I'll go onto Amazon
AWS and go through their machine
learning tutorials don't think to
yourself I'm not technical enough
or I'm not gonna get this or I don't get
into this or it's too much try it get as
far as you can because it's like doing a
basic website and a little bit of HTML
just having done that you feel smarter
and you feel a little bit more confident
about this you know I don't want to be
an alarmist but I'm trying to scare the
hell out of you because it's important
also if you want to build confidence
like Mark Cuban checking my 250 for
confidence series it's free and the link
is in the description below I've always
been passionate some people say you know
it's a it's more OCD than anything else
rule number 5 have a unique advantage we
just sold a company out of Atlanta that
went on Shark Tank a slight cyclorama
k-- they had the iPhone that used the
buzzer and you ran this app on it and it
just turned around and did a panoramic
version of the phone of took panoramic
pictures well they changed the format of
the iPhone which is great this is a
great lesson for entrepreneurs right so
this guy came in with this really cool
app worked with an iPhone 5 and it just
turn around and take panoramic pictures
and then stitch them together and it was
a cool picture well not so I give him
$250,000 I think for 20% of the company
or 25% of the company not four months
later Apple changes the iPhone and it's
got this like rounded thing underneath
some were like what what are we gonna do
but the guy was smart and one of the
things I always look for for companies
coming in is what's your unique
advantage what is the one thing you have
that differentiates you from other
companies and for this guy the product
was interesting but you know as I said
on the show the ability to program video
and use what became computer vision was
a unique skill that was hard to find and
so we worked with him and actually
brought it worked with him to bring in
another CEO and they used that same
technology to be able to scan cars so
now if you go to websites like carvanha
to buy a car and you see how you can
turn the car around just right there
that started with their software and the
guy's name is bruno so bruno we just
sold his company for twenty two and a
half million dollars a couple weeks ago
and so i walked away with you know
five percent of that so I was like yeah
sartet ruin every six sees opportunity
amazon's the world's greatest startup
Netflix is the world greatest next which
makes it harder to innovate if you were
if you were still dreaming starting all
over yeah I still think you can still
kick their ass right you yes because I
think on the March
you can't even at that scale even with
all the AI that they both use they're
still on the margin places to make money
where they're inefficient because it's
still it's it's still vertical and it
still takes time to get to the to the
edges and so I think there's a lot of
opportunities for small companies to
come in and you're seeing a lot of that
now like you see growth acts on
Kickstarter where I have one of my
companies a shark tank company that all
they do their whole entire business now
is just releasing products on
Kickstarter
delivering them and then going on to the
next product okay and it's just a pure
growth act there's other companies that
they measure what's selling the best on
Amazon and then they go out and buy
those products brand them and sell just
on Amazon and buy Amazon it's just its
own little ecosystem where we're kids
are I try to give this kid some money
right literally because he was so good
at it uh-huh
didn't need it he was already making you
know a million dollars a year working an
hour a day just by tracking Amazon
really yeah and it's just so you can be
smart because there's just so big rule
number seven make that first step we all
are entrepreneurs or wonder if we're
entrepreneurs at heart you know we all
have that idea inside of us we've all
been through it I got this idea it's a
great idea you know when you get all
excited to get that feeling in your
stomach right and then you go to Google
and you go ah there's nobody else doing
this then you call your friends you go
what do you think what do you think all
that it's really cool I'd buy one you
know and then most people stop yeah
what's for dinner but some people they
found their way to turn those into
companies and they found their way onto
shark tank and we got to see examples of
people from any little town and any you
know anywhere in the country with
backgrounds that weren't from some big
Ivy League school maybe you didn't go to
college at all maybe it was their last
dollar and they started it up and and
they were desperate to get an investment
but they started it and we showed
examples of people who were willing to
take that first step and and start that
company and work and go and I think that
really into this day really excites
people and gets that encourages them and
really shows them that there can be an
upside and on the flip side you know
there can be failure too and so you have
to be realistic about what can happen
remember a noted before you scout it the
other thing is when people get some
momentum they want to all of a sudden go
big right particularly that's kind of a
dot-com thing that's by our customers
raised a ton of money well one of my
buddies Howard Tallman says the best he
goes you got to nail it before you scale
it if your company doesn't work making a
big won't solve your problems will just
add to your problems rule number nine
value time we're gonna get to in my
opinion we're gonna get to a point where
decisions are made individually on
arbitrage of time right we'll value our
time you'll value your time that's the
whole goober economy right where people
say what's it worth we do that now we do
it what's it worth for me versus I can
hire somebody right and that somebody
can be for ten minutes that somebody can
be for ten hours it could be for two
seconds like when a couple my companies
we have scripts now for Mechanical Turk
on Amazon where might cost us a penny
the label thinks really oh it's crazy
right I invested in a company because
the guy was a computer vision genius oh
he does his hand puppets so you do like
this you know hand puppets like you do
with your kids when you're little right
right only it digitizes it using AI cuz
he has to write computer vision and AI
scripts that say okay this is a knuckle
here's a second knuckle here's the thumb
right and I'm gonna recognize show
that's facially right and all that stuff
is advanced computer vision but it all
goes back to you know hiring people
based off the value
time when I make decisions build versus
buy robotics are now part of the
decision you know it's you know what's
the most cost-effective way what's going
to give me the best return what's gonna
be the path of least resistance for me
effectively yeah and now it's not just
okay who can I hire it's alright what
can I hire rule number ten do things
your way I went to Dallas after college
cuz a bunch of my buddies were down
there and I got a job working as a
bartender at night and was looking for a
job during the day and got a job working
for a retail software company and this
was in the early days of PCs and was
doing okay there and then about nine
months in I'm eight um let me add I was
living six guys in a three-bedroom
apartment and I was sleeping on the
floor
it was the raddest nastiest hole you've
ever seen in your life
I mean and I literally didn't have a
closet didn't have a drawer all my was
in a pile on the floor I had my one
towel that I stole from Motel six that
had a hole in it that was mine
and so I was trying to grind it out and
learn tech which I really realized that
I loved and I made the one day I called
up my boss a guy named Michael Hume X hu
m ec ki and I said Michael I've got this
deal I'm gonna close now it's $1,500
Commission to me which meant I can move
out of the store and and so I said um
one of my responsibilities was to open
up the retail store you know make sure
the door is open the floors were clean
and all that kind of stuff I said look
I've got this big deal I want to close
it and he said no you need to be at the
storm like I got someone to watch
because no you need to be at the store
so I made the executive decision that if
I went and picked up a fifteen thousand
dollar check for this company your
business software he would see the light
and all would be good and I'd have my
fifteen hundred dollar Commission fired
my ass um seriously Michael Hugh Mickey
and spoken since then one time one time
literally after broadcast comm one
public he sent me a letter asking if I
was interested his company you should
bring him on Shark Tank
anyway so that was the only time I
talked to Michael he meki and now I've
got a special bonus Mark Cuban rule on
how to make smart decisions that I
really think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching a video to taking action
here we go question number one where do
you need to value time more number two
what's that first step that you need to
take today and number three what is the
opportunity in front of you that you
need to seize I had watched in the 80s
you know these PC companies go Bam Bam
Eagle computing names you wouldn't even
remember go bam bam bam then I watched
software company WordPerfect you know
ashton-tate you know word star all these
companies BAM and then networking comes
I mean it didn't take a genius to say
wow this might happen again and so the
first thing I did the minute we sold I
wasn't allowed to put on a collar for
six months because of the loss and so
what I was allowed to do was find an
index in internet index that didn't have
yahoo is more than 5% I took every penny
that I had literally every single penny
that I had and bought puts on that index
that got me to the point where I could
put on my collar I lost 90% of that all
those puts but I was able to put on my
collar on the other side and you know
the rest they call one of the top ten
trades and histories
if you want more Mark Cuban check out
the top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there nothing you can't
accomplish in life with the right amount
of work the challenge is you know are
you willing to do the work